[Musik]
was genau bei jetzt willkommen baden
regio leute stets gut ich habe heute
nach wirklich sehr sehr langer zeit also
zumindest du warst verletzte mann im
video aber nicht so wirklich in dem
video mit drin meister deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht ich habe immer wieder mein
bruder mit dabei ich bin gerade älter
und da ergibt sich dass ich hab nämlich
vor gästen oder so eine echt coole video
der auf youtube gefunden und hab ich zum
video gefunden da wurde einfach so logos
gezeigt also mit einfach so markenlogo
ist jeder kennt macdonald playstation
apple samsung und so weiter was halt
jeder irgendwie in seinem kopf so
abgespeichert hat und in dem video
wurden halt so fotos gezeigt wo die
marke einmal mit dem fake logo
dargestellt ist und einmal ist das
rieder logo zu sehen und dann gibt's so
ganz kleine unterschied ich kann euch
jemand beispiel zeigen kurz von whatsapp
haben wir aber das feld logo und hätten
wir das original logo also die richtung
soll deshalb gehen wir haben es jetzt
jeder fünf logos rausgesucht also einmal
das video und einmal ein fake logo und
zeigen dass dem andern dann muss der
andere einfach so schnell wie möglich
heiraten würde ich sogar ich fähig ist
und welches genau also ich will gar
nicht lang lagern lassen darum dafür die
tolle idee wenn ihr noch ein paar davon
sehen wollt und wir machen jetzt scheint
not wer anfängt bis 1 schnick schnack
schnuck okay das heißt du darfst mich
okay leute also ich bin gespannt metzger
das erste los von spotify aber das ist
schon richtig beraten auch auf jeden
fall bei jedem logo mit also schreibt
einfach in die kommentare zum beispiel
spotify und danach oder b wie man es
jetzt hier sieht das kann man jetzt
entscheiden
oder man kann es jetzt eigentlich darin
sehen ob dem echten oberhalb vier
striche sind oder nur 3 ich würde aber
sagen dass echte logisch richtig
so deute ich würde sagen zu meinem
ersten logo und zwar ist es echt schwer
also ich es selber nicht gewusst dhl
kann jeder das sind die netten menschen
wie euch das rechte so ist das ruile
bist du ganz sicher ja ganz sicher
da liegst du leider falsch weil das
echte logo sieht halt jeglichen strich
also einmal oben hier und einmal um
im echten leben sind ja echt beide unten
die spricht keiner wusste ich auch und
ich hätte auch gesagt das rechte oder
stets ruhig mal sagen also für mich war
gestern meine friseurin wollte meine
haare noch ein bisschen passen irgendwie
da sieht man daran gar nichts ok es muss
logos von apple und davon den ganzen
soll jetzt ein echtes ermitteln
ich sag mal so ich nur minimal hierdurch
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 und ich sage das achte
logo ist das echt dann ist wohl richtig
ist richtig also weiter damit hätte das
auch gewusst weil ich finde man sieht
dass die anderen äpfel sind alle voll
komisch ausgeschnitten okay ich habe
noch was ist gefunden man glaubt dass er
so und zwar habe ich hier supreme was
mainz ist fake und was ist wie oben oder
unten schreibt die kommentare was glaubt
ihr
der unterschied ist jetzt einfach noch
dicker sind der unterschied man sieht es
ja so ein bisschen an der qualität sag
ich mal
wobei es halt auf ist also ich hätte es
anders herum gesagt sagen muss man so
vielleicht als kleiner tipp ihr in
serbien ja aber was soll das ist ja nur
bedrucken hier ja ja ich war oder
besteck und das untere das untere ist
das anderes und das ist richtig aber ich
hätte eigentlich gesagt das obere war
soo bereit viel besser aber ich kenne
das ja von meinem t-shirt das ist
eigentlich dicker ist so die schrift das
nächste ist von gruppe
haig den unterschied klar ach so ja
einmal ist das rot und einmal ist es
gelb wollte ich gemobbt
nein ich würde sagen dass pro also ich
würde sagen eigentlich bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher dass es links rechts
oder eigentlich ist es wichtig einfach
auf den ersten eindruck zu hören wenn
man ein foto als erstes sieht oder wenn
man so nur als erstes sieht man hat es
ja im gehirn sag ich mal so
abgespeichert
das unterbewusstsein verrichten dann
sofort den ersten eindruck was man denkt
und wenn man dann auch weiter überlegt
dann kommt man vielleicht irgendwann auf
die fährten das vielleicht das andere
logo richtig ist also der erste eindruck
ist glaube ich am wichtigsten
ok jetzt ist es echt schwer also das
hätte ich auch anders herum gesagt
willkommen zum playstation logo
obwohl das müsste eigentlich wissen sind
sodass eines länger sich das linke das
linke ist das so
bis der ganze ja da würde ich noch mal
darüber nachdenkt ist sicher nein es ist
recht fertig kann die sogar zeigen
theorie doch nicht schlecht
wie steht es eigentlich warte mal das
heißt ja 30 mich ja doch alle richtig
gerade durch einen falsch gehörten
ich habe alles richtig geraten 3 1 für
mich
so jetzt musst du aber punkten der
saison mein gott das ist ja schon wieder
das mit den farben
ich sage einfach mal das recht ist
hahaha das ist so schwer ich habe auch
erst am anfang sofort gedacht dass linke
aber irgendwie sieht das richtig obwohl
links ist ich habe halt kein microsoft
microsoft hat diese chance jetzt steht
immer noch 3 1 für mich nur das heißt
man muss jetzt zwei punkte untereinander
erzielten gleich schon zu erzielen es
gibt noch zwei bilder und zwar wird es
jetzt eigentlich meiner meinung nach am
schwersten und zwar haben wir hier
macdonald was sagst du ja einmal geht es
und einmal nicht leute was sagt ihr
schreibt zudem kommentare links oder
rechts oder müsst ihr auf jeden tag ich
bin fast nie weil ist eklig findet dazu
auch schon mal früher
ich sage das rechnen dass rechte ist
bisher sicher ja das stimmt ich habe
aber eigentlich erst gesagt also ich
habe erst gedacht man fährt ja so oft an
so macdonald
vorbei und ich dachte wirklich dass es
dann etwas komplett immer auf dem boden
geht also da war ich überrascht so
willkommen zum nächsten und das einmal
gehen die beine misst auch einmal gegen
die beine dadurch und einmal sind die
abgetrennt so ich würde sagen ich glaube
das recht es ist nicht wie der kunde
witz dieses android das habe ich schon
fast vergessen dass es ist das überhaupt
noch gibt so samsung handys werden mit
android betriebene aber das logo hab ich
schon ewig nicht mehr gesehen dass place
tore war noch auch für dieses logo aber
ist jetzt eine andere heißt es steht
jetzt 32 also leute 32 jeder muss noch
ein foto erraten ich kann jetzt noch
gewinnen oder mehr gemacht und
entschieden und ich glaube für das
letzte benutzen wir einfach mal dass
netflix logo das ist eine super aufnahme
ist gerade angehalten er hat gesagt das
geköpfte also das recht du dich auch
schon
also ich hatte auch gesagt dass rechte
aber das ist dann halt schwer zu sagen
weil wer achtet darauf dass ihr körper
ist oder nicht so und wenn ich jetzt
aber noch das richtig erwarte ich habe
schon 1 5 gezeigt
das steht jetzt 33 ja hast du noch ein
spot steht 3 3
wir müssen jetzt noch eins zum stechen
machen willst du anfang okay leute einem
netzwerk das stechen es steht 3 3 und
aldi logo ich bin nie bei aldi ein
meistens oben horizontal gespiegelt und
das war es aber eigentlich oder die
fragen ehrlich muss raten ich sag
einfach mal
ich sage das linke oder was gesagt dass
linke hat das ist sogar das rechte bein
ist finde ich jetzt eigentlich leicht
oder was heißt leicht welches ist will
samsung wir haben hier ein samsung auf
ladekabel adapter oder was das ist was
meinst du links oder rechts mit links
das linke knie
wenn du dir sicher ja das recht herzlich
platz gewonnen
das war unser logo erwarten format ich
hoffe ihr habt ordentlich mit geraten
und dem kommentare lese ich mir gleich
mal fleißig durch ich würde sagen ich
hoffe dass wieder durchgefallen check
war bei mehreren bei instagram vorbei
ist hier eingeblendet wenn du glück hast
und wir sind uns da nächste woche wieder
ich wünsche euch eine schöne woche und